so who's entitled women oh because they
because because they're not tra we're
not traditional exactly that's the point
so it's like we're asking for
traditional a 25-year-old was probably a
24 year-old was born MH not that long
ago 24 years ago we in a society where
this is not a part of their Norm what
isn't a part of the norm to be
traditional right so you are raised you
she's being raised to to be a part of a
masculine world that is what the norm is
now right so a more traditional woman is
probably going to be older but
unfortunately she's been cut off because
she's
expired no I would say more traditional
women um are going to be married it's
traditional right because traditional
women get married before the age of 25
typically